I just want to address from the top of
this video that I know that this plant
looks like it's dying but it's fine it
has water it's just being dramatic with
that out of the way hello everyone I'm
Alana o'charalonas added welcome to my
channel where today we are talking about
episode four of The Last of Us TV show
I've been doing these solo reviews every
week while I'm also on Twitch playing
through the game as the TV show is so
right now I'm streaming the things that
happen in episode four and I'm doing a
weekly talk show with a bunch of cool
guests this week is Eddie burback and
Nikki Jakey next week which I have to
figure out how to schedule it because
the episode is if you didn't know
actually coming out on Friday episode 5
is airing Friday instead of Sunday
because of the Super Bowl sports are a
bit more important than the last of us
apparently I agree to disagree but the
next one is with Kate Siegel and Mike
Flanagan um and a whole bunch more
really cool guests lined up so that's
been very fun basically I'm just I'm
sorry if there's too much Last of Us
content I'm just really enjoying it so
episode 4 of The Last of Us uh gave me
something that I been waiting for for a
really long time that I knew would be
coming and that I knew that they would
pay off well and I keep saying I always
had Faith but it was something that I
really wanted to see which is the
relationship between Joel and Ellie
starting to soften I think this might be
the first time we've actually seen
Joel's smile outside of flashbacks again
I understand that they lived in a really
messed up world but but yeah I really
feel like a lot of this is a game that
is about
people about love about
um as Troy said long-term relationships
about how two people coexist in extreme
circumstances obviously episode three
really dove into that episode four is
giving us that uh in a very very
different way they are outside of the
safe haven of something like episode 3
and in the real world dealing with the
realities of other people
um and I think it's really interesting
having episode 4 come right after what
episode three was about because episode
3 is two people existing and living
together in a space episode four is what
happens if they actually venture out and
make friends and take those risks we're
seeing the thing that Joel had warned
Bill about which is you know the Raiders
will come obviously they did come in
episode three but this is like an
extension of that so I think having
these two episodes back to back was um a
really good idea and episode four is the
shortest in the show 45 minutes and it
was very fast but I think it also is
sort of a bridge of an episode it is an
episode that fills in a lot of
information that we need to take us
further rather than really pushing out
characters very far they're in the call
we knew they were in the car they get to
the city
some some action happens but that's
actually as far as they they really go
the journey here is more about their
relationship again finally
um Ellie in the game and Joel in the
game are much much much closer even
before they get to the city pacing of a
video game is very different and of
course in a video game you need to care
about the person you're protecting
because you the player are invested in
them so it's a very different setup and
I totally understand why it was
different but I also think this
episode's really powerful because of the
like
stock violence of the episode this
episode is brutal it is a show of the
world that Joel ultimately has to try to
save Ellie from though well that he
couldn't save Sarah from this is people
hurting people people shooting people
people dying and so having the two
themes of this episode essentially be
violence and companionship was a really
smart idea in my opinion and I think the
beats that cause Joel and only to
finally kind of self into each other a
little bit like Ellie was always trying
she was harsh and Brash and and kind of
a little bit of an annoying teenager but
she was always trying to talk to him he
really wasn't opening up and I think
seeing the stakes of the world actually
play out directly in front of her really
for the first time seem to have softened
him this is an episode in which he
refers to her as cargo and you're not
family you're cargo and then very
quickly says you know you shouldn't have
to deal with any of this it happened
quite quickly in this episode that they
suddenly got a lot closer he finally
laughed at one of her puns the magazine
thing I keep saying this but I love the
stuff that is one to one the same in the
game and the show and I love that it
doesn't feel like fan service because
it's actually just brilliantly written
and was originally it makes perfect
sense to lift the conversation about the
magazine word for word because it is
identical I just streamed it tonight
after watching the episode yesterday she
says the exact same things I think they
both do to have that be identical is
like so fun for everybody who played the
game but it doesn't feel like cheap fan
service it's it feels earned because it
perfectly belongs exactly where they put
it which is just so impressive and such
a testament to what naughty dog did in
terms of Storytelling in the first place
and I also just love like Ellie's puns
keep showing up in moments that are
otherwise very tense extremely tense
happening in the forest where they're
concerned that they are going to be
attacked and there is definitely a lot
of build up to climax of this episode or
what it's heading towards it's fun for
the audience I think like for me at home
to like you know see these moments of
tension of of Ellie asking if they're
going to be okay and Joel lying to her
and saying no one's going to come for us
even though he couldn't possibly know
and like that definitely being a
fatherly kind of paternal thing to do is
tell her she's okay even if she's not to
be honest certainly I think Joel does
plenty of is like when do you be honest
to your kid that's an interesting thing
to discover
but like those moments are sort of
sliced through in like I think pretty
much expert timing in this episode with
jokes and they're not slapstick jokes
it's all just like Ellie trying to make
the mood lighter so it works you know
it's not it's not uh some weird quip
that doesn't land it's somebody who is
even if they're puns and we think
they're silly I think for the audience
it works because what she's trying to do
for Joel actually works for us at home
like it's just such a smart pairing and
again for an episode that's pretty dark
and I suspect the next episode is going
to be super messed up it's nice to have
an option for us to like not go like
full depression and still have faith and
care for these two people as an audience
as well and I think that at the start of
this which is like a little bit of a
road trip
um leading into the city just all looks
so good this show is just so good
looking and so visually impressive it's
stunning the cities are incredible all
of those cars like I just am blown away
by these sets they're so big
and so detailed it's
I otherwise feel like this is basically
one of our first like action combat
scenes and I actually really want to
note that I really like the way it was
shot when they get into the city
the Ambush occurs of course we've seen
that in the game too in the game it's
you know shoot out
um in the show it's desperation you know
Joel is there telling Ellie to hide
which of course doesn't happen or have
to happen at all in the game but yeah it
was very um like kind of shaky a lot of
different perspectives you're seeing
them behind the car and hearing things
in the background from sort of over the
shoulder like I just I really really
liked the way that the action was shot
in this episode very sort of dramatic
frantic didn't look
um like a polished war zone just suits
the aesthetic of the show really well I
think they really nailed that and it's
something that that easily could have
fallen apart for a show that really does
have to be about humans it just seems
like it would be an easy thing to mess
up the action
um and so I was paying extra attention
to it and I felt like it was super well
directed it's like everyone in this
world and everything in this world is
like rough around the edges and
um the combat or the action it's still
calling it combat like it's video game
the action looked that way to me too
which was cool so obviously
um the biggest moment in this episode
was
Ellie shooting someone which was very
very different from the game and once
again and even in a different place to
the game I think and I think that was
really because
in a TV show for a TV show audience it's
probably a little harder to watch to
have her actually kill somebody as a
child it's pretty brutal but I think it
also having this journey go in this
Direction with part two or season two in
mind in theory makes a lot of sense that
kind of this is where we're starting
from but I'm sure we will see her kill
someone throughout the season now in
fact I'm like positive that that will
happen after this episode though of
course she's alluding to it having
happened before anyway but yes
definitely a big moment and
um the guy who got shot don't know what
his name is but like everything he was
saying that performance
wow he was acting his heart out that was
intense very dramatic very gritty real
like harrowing look at again what that
universe is like uh it was super
confronting I think they did a really
really good job of setting up those
Stakes end of at every step of the way
humanizing the other side humanizing the
people who are trying to find them I
think that especially applies when it's
a pretty young guy that that Ellie
shoots and Ellie also being so young is
like it's not like she was shooting some
old objectively evil man she's also kind
of shooting a kid he's probably older
than her but just one of the first times
we're getting the question of like who
is the good guy and who is the bad guy
which I definitely think is a big theme
in the last of us as well I definitely
did think it was an interesting choice
um that
she wanted a gun so bad
and kept playing it so cool
um that when she finally had to actually
use one she was very very hesitant and
was a little bit but not too distressed
about it afterwards I think that choice
is interesting
because we don't know what's going to
happen with her character Arc just yet
she's obviously not the same as game
Ellie at this point they are very
different characters in a lot of ways
just on a similar Journey right Joel is
quite different too to be honest Joel I
think is is closer to the game but um
he's a lot quieter a lot more
standoffish a lot more guarded than Joel
is in the game at this point as well so
I just I think that one's interesting
like I don't know what to make of it yet
it's going to fulfill or fill in later
that she used a gun and had a reaction
to it and what her reaction meant she
wasn't unaffected which is a choice they
could have gone with but she also wasn't
distraught she was hesitant but not so
hesitant that she wouldn't do it to
protect Joel there's a lot to unpack
there and I'm excited for what that sets
up for future episodes which I think is
how I felt about a lot of this episode
it's like this episode is a very good
Bridge doesn't feel like filler at all
it's the show is so fast I think I'm
gonna be upset when the show's over to
be honest
like enjoying watching it so much but um
it's definitely an episode that's like
pushing us in a direction of like here's
a little bit more about the world and
the direction that you are heading in
and is your relationship strong enough
to survive this I think that Joel is
also just definitely very much a person
of um he's he's realistic and he's loyal
but he is also like quietly
compassionate and now that Ellie saved
his life in the way that she had here
that loyalty shows up where he
previously didn't have any the minute
that that happened uh he for as much as
he was fighting it can no longer pretend
she's cowgirl she didn't stand he didn't
stand a chance to keep up that facade
any longer and again I think that they
paced it really well they could have
done this too quickly they could have
done it too slowly I think um you know
being just under or like technically at
halfway of the show it's weird because
it's nine episodes so four and a half
it's half having them finally get a
little bit closer now I think is is very
well timed and yeah having that be the
core of like what really broke Joel down
is violence in a violent world where
violent things are happening just just
very it's perfect there are pieces of it
that are so perfect and that's most of
what they do in this episode except at
the very end where yeah Ellie finally
tells a joke
and he finally laughs um which was very
nice way to end things
uh
outside of the very very ending which
we'll get to so otherwise this episode
is about a group of survivors and I
think it's the first time we'd seen them
fleshed out in this way
um Kathleen was the name of the the main
enemy character here who's obviously
obsessed with finding Henry and I would
think that this is probably like my
really only like notable criticism of
this episode is that uh while I liked
seeing more insight this episode really
does feel like um like I said in a lot
of ways a very very good bridge in this
way I wasn't sure why I needed to know
about Kathleen and her desire
specifically I get that it's there and I
get that it's gonna be an episode two
but there wasn't anything about it other
than her being desperate in it as a
woman I don't know that made me go oh I
really want to find out why she wants
Henry like I didn't it didn't spark that
in me to a super strong extent so was
like maybe this episode could have been
a little bit longer but at the same time
I felt like every episode could have
been a little bit longer it must have
been so hard to choose what to cut from
this show but this woman Kathleen is
clearly very very obsessed um and yeah I
wasn't sure totally what the um purpose
of the doctor scene is of him saying you
know I was your childhood doctor and and
then going to shoot the doctor I suspect
that that was to touch on how people's
relationships go out the window and
don't really matter
um you can know someone your whole life
someone who delivered you I think is
what he said and still get rid of them
in times of desperation I think is like
if you're on that side of the world
which is like not to what Joel and Ellie
are going to do so I think it's probably
a reflection of that but some of that is
like I I have no doubt it'll pay off in
the next episode and I'll understand why
it's there in the next episode it's not
even so it's not even really a criticism
it's just like a thing that I like maybe
would have liked a little bit more info
on why I want to be looking forward to
what's happening with Kathleen next
episode rather than just Joel and Ellie
which is obviously where I'm at right
now maybe
to get into that Italian
I was definitely interested in seeing
that little cracked the concrete thing
at the bottom of the building which I
immediately assumed was a blowda it
seems like most people I've spoken to
assumed was a bloda but we still
ultimately don't know if that is what
that was I look forward to finding out
if that's right or wrong but that was
clearly a point there where Kathleen
ignored that in effort to search for her
brother which is like her whole thing
and for
um the person who in this case uh
seemingly ratted out her brother to
fedra which is Henry I suspect that
everything had happened with Kathleen
and it will happen in the next episode
which you know if it's going to be like
the games I am anticipating to be
quite weighty and sad is just
foreshadowing for everything that
continues to happen with Joel and Ellie
going forward and I'm already excited to
re-watch this show I'm already excited
to finish it and have all of the context
of like have all the questions I have
now answered and be like oh this is
probably paced this way for this reason
or this is here for this reason and then
to re-watch the whole thing without like
constantly asking those questions and
just get to absorb it like I'm already
excited to do that so yeah as a as a
story in itself this episode actually
doesn't cover a lot it is a bridge
between two episodes maybe I would have
liked it to be a little bit longer but I
had the thing that I really really
wanted from this episode which was
finally the sort of connection growing
between Joel and Ellie to make us really
care about them and enjoy seeing them
together where previously it was two
people who didn't even really seem to
like each other where that growth
happens much much much faster in the
games they are already friends before
they meet Bill pretty much and it's
interesting to see how different mediums
have to tackle these different themes
and how they have to pace things and by
no surprise I think they really nailed
it here and they chose the right moments
to do it and it's just really nice to
watch a show where people just making
something that's very good it's great so
then of course the very end is they go
to sleep in the room they wake up to um
Henry and this is the only time since
watching the show that I went damn I
wish I hadn't played the games because
the end of this episode is very much a
cliffhanger for TV audiences it is not
at all a cliffhanger for game audiences
we already know that they are safe
of course unless they're doing something
wildly different but I don't imagine so
I imagine episode 5 is going to play out
in a very similar way but you know to
have them go to sleep have a warning
about
um about how he can't hear on a certain
side or the noise or whatever and then
have them wake up
um and see the look on Ellie's face and
be like oh [__] I assumed it would be
Kathleen but um it was Henry makes sense
that it went down that way but it was
like oh well
I know they're fine I don't know exactly
how that's gonna play out but I know
they're okay which is the only time that
I've been like bummer damn the
Cliffhanger was not really so much of a
cliffhanger for the people who played
the game but yes I continue to really
enjoy the show and to enjoy it being a
weekly release and I'm liking talking to
people about it and watching other
people talk about it it's like been a
really fun Community event
um looking forward to next week I expect
it to be heartbreaking